ليس لها من اسمها نصيب هكذا تقول سعيده
المقعده في مخيم السويداء بمارب والنازحه
في دروب التعاسه منذ ثمان سنوات من حريب
نهم الى هنا مرت سعيده وابنائها باربع
محطات نزوح كانت جميعها وسط نيران
الاشباكات ومع كل محطه كانت تتوفر فيها
الخدمات تصل المقذوفات الحوثيه
لتجبرهم على تغيير مخيم النزوح وبدء
معاناه جديده
حول سعيده التي اصبحت بحالها هذا المربيه
الاطفال
في الحرب اطفال لا يجدون في خيام مم قد ما
يقيهم قسوه البرد في مناطق صحراويه مفتوحه
والبطانيه كانوا كانوا فوق البطانيه من
البرد من هذا البرد عسر الحمد لله
في المخيمات معرضه لموجه البرد الشديده
منها 60000 واسره بحاجه شديده وماسه همم
لاحتياجات الايواء والماء منها الحقائب
الشتويه ووسائل التدفئه الاخرى همم مثل
البدلات الشتويه
ومواد الايواء الفرشان والبطانيات وغيرها
من الادوات
استقبلت ماربو اكثر من مليونينزحا هجرتهم
الميليشيات الحوثيه من محافظات مختلفه لكن
المعاناه الاشد هي تكرار النزوح داخليا
بين مديريات المحافظه لا تنحصر المعاناه
على مخيمات النازحين فقط فماربوا بمدينتها
واطرافها تجمع كبير لنزوح محمود الحميدي
لقناه العربيه مارب